welcome back to new rockstars new
Christmas edition yeah gobble-gobble
we're gonna keep talking about some new
Avengers for updates guys Avengers for
these updates keep coming out and we're
gonna talk about every single one of
them because there's information and all
of them
now we're also we also got some news on
the timeline for the new Joker origin
movie the joaquin phoenix one and some
exciting rumors about the new disney
streaming service shows out of the ashes
of netflix marvel come gold that's how
it works but first we should explain
ourselves right it's a Halloween costume
theme this year and it's mashups
everyone so as I introduce us I will say
what on earth we are wearing I'm Erik
Voss and I am a shark eating a hot dog
and I'm the hot dog quick flash uh oh
you didn't see that coming because the
character died at the end I am buried
eyes usually so I'm just a dead
character for two different properties
turd rolling in the wind in Maude
Garrett oh hey I'm Harley putter
so Harley Quinn and Harry Potter I'm
trying to think of instead of like hey
put in its hey pumpkin that's all I got
okay we're working on it I got this scar
Phillips what on earth are you peewee
he-man
we don't most of us don't get either of
those references anymore but it was me
in a suit it's called the show should
start yes it should now we've also
posted our top three submissions that we
seed from all of you guys on our
Instagram thank you to everyone all the
multitudes of you who sent us your your
mashup costumes people me pouring over
these things oh yeah all week yeah it
was it was wild did ending notifications
ding ding dinging now at the end of the
show we'll announce the winner and we're
so excited to see this but let's get
started with today's show okay so here's
what we're looking at this week we got
confirmation via mixed martial arts
podcast that Frank Grillo will be in
Avengers for remember Frank Grillo or
griot we're not sure we think it's
guerrilla he says that his character
crossbones Frank Wright was named Franco
Brock Frank his name's Frank
but his characters name anyway
crossbones you remember him from Civil
War and Captain America Winter Soldier
he will make an appearance be a
flashback he says mm-hmm you know as a
refresher yeah he's in these movies he
was a Hydra agent with infiltrated
shield he showed up at the beginning of
Captain America Civil War he tries to
blow himself up Scarlet Witch contains
it but then she moves over to a building
and a bunch of innocent civilian
casualties happen that lead to the
sokovia accords now what does frank
grillo coming back into of interest for
mean what could it mean
he says his flashback could a flashback
just be his word for time travel could
it be Tony Stark's barf technology the
memory flashbacks that they used to work
through their past trauma you know the
implant that they have we have seen some
set photos have shown barf showing up on
set possibly in Avengers 4 and is that
is that what that means and lastly in
the comics crossbones does actually kill
Captain America and Bucky takes over it
does seem unlikely but who knows what do
you guys think this news means for
Avengers
bummer voyda in that movie like they
beat Thanos they're out there sniper
snap to me right when they're done and
he says can I be frank with you yeah I
remember that the big rumor at the end
of civil war was that we all thought
Steve Rogers was gonna die at his hands
because of the comic book story so I
feel like they already missed that time
to do that I think he is playing a
little game with us by calling the
flashback my fingers are crossed at his
time-travel flash related but yeah there
you go good Paul last was your back I
know different cinema a flashback ten
points to me no I would rather it not be
the barfs technology because I think
that's a little it's kind of a cop-out
you got the time trap we already played
with it in Avengers infinity war yeah
and I would like them to kind of like
double down on it this is a sharp mask
I'll be honest yeah sharp on the inside
and on my chin flash back to me sounds
like an actor who doesn't fully
understand the cosmic sci-fi concepts
that have been put in the script like
it's a I don't know how to say this
without getting sued by Marvel it's a
flashback flashback is something that's
in every movie so I can say I'm in a
flashback without saying like my
character gets read brought to life in
some crazy trippy way it's just a
flashback that's not controversial or
gonna get me and violation my NDA that's
what that sounds like to me
well the flashback is because you know
we've seen him before why would they go
backwards two characters that we've
already seen that don't really
necessarily hey a pivotal role you know
what I mean well the theory is that that
has been brought up a couple times that
like through trap time travel they go
back to key moments and MCU Castle and
then they they they maybe recruit that
version of Captain America from that
moment when he was just starting to
distrust shield but was like the most
heroic version of Captain America
arguably and they pull like Hulk from
the
you know which version yeah the kid
maybe that's the idea or they just go
back to key moments in their battles
like that elevator moment with like you
know crossbones before he's crossbones
with captain Eric was such a badass
moment so maybe they go revisit that
somehow and they they restage it and I
don't know I'm just trying to get back
to me just sound like a flat I guess
it's a flashback it would be a fair safe
way to describe whatever the hell that
is would be my guess I think I brought
this up right after we saw it where I
was like man it would be so cool and so
dark if they don't bring those people
back but instead they bring alternate
versions of them back yeah because I
mean someone's that died are dead right
there should be consequences right you
don't want to just like reverse things
and he's like they didn't really it's
like we got this person out like the
second before they died and time is
frozen when they died so they get to
live on for eternity until they want to
die like that's uh it's not it's it's a
little bit of a cop-out
I don't but it sounds what it sounds
like and I just don't know if like I
would want to see that on the screen
also I don't know if we're audience just
like get it when they get it like
immediately
I don't know it'd be tough you know I
think maybe if you went into parallel
timelines versus time-travel it's time
travel people start thinking like wait
it's like grandfather paradox like
butterfly wait no the idiot voice
doesn't know the grandfather paradox
anything- online we're hearing here mine
Jeremy Jeremy but I think an alternate
timeline set something you know Rick and
Morty we've talked about that before
right like they're there one of their
big rules on Rick and Morty is to never
explore time travel they have a joke
they're like in the background they have
time-travel stuff on the shelf that they
never use it because they're based on
back to the future loosely and they're
like we don't wanna get into that
instead we'll go into like alternate
dimension version versions of that I
think with stuff like Rick and Morty
people like the idea of alternate
timelines and alternate dimensions and
things like sliders like
people are kind of get it it makes sense
comics there's more of a there's also um
you know there's berries there's six one
six Spurs in the marble world and
there's all these thousands and
thousands of alternate universes so it
wouldn't necessarily be completely out
of left field to introduce the idea of
alternate timelines where history will
played out differently it is funny be
but a brick and mortar you that is
exactly a scenario where they ruined
everything and then left that that
timeline is not shaped by that dimension
and those consequences are so real they
ruined a whole plan and all those people
are dead Cronenberg see 137 years yeah
in the oh boy we're just watching a
clips of the fly which is you see that's
how Avengers four ends I'm gonna be
pissed I gotta say guys I love this like
journey we've been on of like a week a
week
finding an don't work its way over like
a lunar eclipse my head is too big it's
too big no every week or several times
throughout the week there's little
tweets that come out and it gradually
we're gonna piece together all the
different things that this could be and
it's fun to discuss all the things that
it's been a delight that I never thought
we'd get to this much level of fun of
just discussing rumors we did recently
find out that Marvel Studios is aware of
these videos it makes me feel like we're
know maybe they're like no we don't get
people thinking this could be in the
movie they get disappointed with it
actually it's not that true yeah yeah
okay well let us know what you think
this means uh flashbacks what what are
some different things so maybe we didn't
think of that Grillo could be internet
but for now let us move on to this
week's trivia question gif of shame are
the are the consequences for this we
have some new gif of shame possibilities
that we put in the box so who knows
what's in there but let's read this
week's trivia question
our question is we were asking this
before
what is crossbones real name okay all of
our answers are in the blue bin we'll
reveal what the answer is at the end of
the episode and then our loser will have
to join the game as always let's move to
some other news that came out this week
this is gonna be the weirdest gif of
shame where they're just like why is
this hotdog dancing hey guys a redditor
posed an interesting theory this week
this comes from I specifically a
reference to Ant Man and the wasp so in
that movie we see a shot of a video from
an online close-up magic University you
guys thought that didn't matter but it
may be totally matters it's pulled up on
a laptop please we know that Scott Lang
has been learning magic that's all he's
been spending this time and so I the
clip if you're paying attention
it's about misdirection one of the keys
to magic getting the audience to look
somewhere else is the idea so that you
perform the real trick without them
noticing because you have their
attention over here right here's what
gets really interesting specifically the
method that the video is referencing is
saying snap your fingers that gets them
to look over there
ah Snap is a misdirection now a lot of
paranoid fans uh-huh but us included
have a new version like well there's a
very famous finger snap recently in the
MCU could that be foreshadowing that
Thanos his snap is actually just a
distraction for a more horrible more
evil plan and if so what else could
Bannos be up to what is more evil than
eradicating half of all of the universe
what I'll say even though it sounds a
little crazy like well he we built up so
much what he was doing in that movie
like he's know what he was doing but I
will say that I've heard rumors and I
think they have to be true that Avengers
4 is not really only gonna be dealing
with the idea of undoing the snap
there's a whole new problem that they
have to deal with throughout that movie
so it is pretty clear that something
else is probably gonna happen
rushon watts
pretty big try to get the election
figured out yeah well I mean you gotta
think about what the slate is coming up
marble right whatever goes on there
that's then you think
well the scrolls will be added to the
MCU at that point think about this I
think there's a video on this channel
there is I made it it's about the
villains that could come after Thanos
right one villain that would be that
that's grander that's bigger they got
wider scale valent you could play with
his king and he's a time-travel
character so you could have someone that
actually may be influenced
Thanos his own journey through this like
why would he even why would he even know
about going on this journey in the first
place and he's like well I need to get
things lined up for what I need to do so
I'm gonna stare at a time traveler yeah
so who has the time stone and who knows
what the best course of action is Doctor
Strange that could put the time line
theory into effect I like it see 20
points to Gryffindor I'd say maybe leads
to King and that there's a lot of
time-travel e problems we had and also
the MCU is only like dabbling the time
travel is like minimal it's always just
like back a couple seconds minutes and
it's like no no no let's go let's go ham
let's go full on back to the future ride
at Universal where they like are flying
all through time stuck in a volcano yeah
I think um I think if anything it is a
meta thing by like the the filmmakers in
the studio right because like
realistically a man in the waswas being
shot and produced separately I don't
know how much Peyton Reed knew about the
ending of infinity world while he was
like writing and shooting ant-man in the
wasp however I could imagine if I get
being like no this will be a fun thing
just from a meta level because yeah as
we have seen with infinity war they
intentionally like led us into thinking
specific characters could die and they
blew us away by killing off half of them
like that was a big misdirect I think it
would be interesting if in yeah it was
that and like we actually did it no one
expected that well I'm sure some people
did but in Avengers 4 I would be a
little disappointed if it only just
dealt with the aftermath of the snap
you're talking about a movie that's
gonna pivot into phase four there's so
many that there's so many things you
could introduce there from mutants now
that you have a licensed control to the
x-men universe Scrolls as we talked
about with yeah why not introduce this
idea of everyone you've seen before half
of them in this case or actually scroll
Impostors and there's all kinds of
things just the idea of a misdirect are
you saying am i in humans could be
scrolled because I watched it not taking
responsibility is there support system
they could be I got I'll tell somebody
this is a big deal I'm interested yeah
so the only thing alter I like your idea
that you're kind of saying like it's
almost like a more meta level like it's
like a larger level of Mister egg
but I will say Peyton Reed of course had
to know about the snap post post credit
scene they could have yet I could have
been a reshoots after the fact and Russo
brothers directed that scene to they
like like et directed the Thor Ragnarok
poster the ant-man post-credit scene for
Civil War aha
yeah yeah well let us know what you
think oh yeah I think the snap might be
too much if it's like literally a snap
doesn't exist or the snap isn't
something real or it's just foreboding
something in the universe but I think
from the filmmakers perspective it could
be a meta thing let's move on I got some
news I want to talk about regarding the
Disney streaming service and it's shows
there been some rumors and rumblings
about these shows for the upcoming
Disney streaming service app this week
first being the idea that maybe the
cancellation of a Netflix is Ironfist
our IP and Luke Cage bigger I our IP
means that the Heroes for Hire show that
we've been thinking about for years is
in the works though Luke Cage Jennifer's
often both play a big part in Heroes for
Hire in the comics and that would be
cool it's really just a conspiracy
theory at this point did you say that
you would quit the internet if daredevil
was cancelled I would be SuperDuper
bummed an you just cancel American
vandals so I'm not feeling real great
right one more
even three that would have loved that
we also still have the Loki and Scarlet
Witch shows in the works and then lastly
there's been some talk about a potential
Nick Fury show and now people are saying
that that's not true but there is
something coming that is bigger and
better than a Nick Fury show that's the
rumblings online right now yes no way
better way cool lasers I know it does
look really good but what are you guys
thoughts on the bigger and better show
and what it could be about what
characters could we be dealing with
maybe teams could we actually finally
see the freeform almost had was Squirrel
Girl remember that show they had it for
a second then it got cancelled like now
I will find a place for it I never
happened on the powerpack not New
Mutants it's the young the young uns the
young be like a Captain Marvel asks you
know rescuer there you go and now that I
love that show no she is over on marvel
rising the new animated show playing
Squirrel Girl so good for her you made
it there but no yeah what kind of
characters would you want to see on this
I think taking MCU proper characters
moving them over
wouldn't it be confusing if they move
the Netflix characters over or does em I
think no no way the CW sold
Buffy over to UPN and then Supergirl one
from CBS nice reference yeah Supergirl
and Constantine they just like took him
from any so you know yeah that happened
over here yeah I'd love to see some
version of damage control right that was
exactly what I think in the works at
first and then they and then they did
what they were gonna do both there were
two versions of the same idea and I
think neither happened right well they
did one on NBC they had an actual show
yeah like every revamping and they they
started with the same idea of the ground
controls maybe feel people yeah I feel
people in on what that is so damage
control it's it's a from the Marvel
Comics it's basically the ground level
world it's almost like agents of shield
but more specifically it's the people
who have to clean up all the messes
every time like there's some calamity
like after the Battle of New York or
after sokovia or after the Triskelion
disaster like they're the people who are
like sweeping up and it's almost like a
kind of an office type comedy but they
deal with the aftermath and rather than
like the secret agent world of agents of
shield it's more of like you know
cleanup crew a little like vultures
story and because you have damage
control now but it would be fun to get
like a workplace comedy i watch
powerless it could've been better had
some good moments could have been better
but I got cancelled so yeah too late for
that shows a lot of interference on that
show but I think if it's just like
complete Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
controlled version of this I think there
could be a really fun version of that on
the new Disney streaming app see that
yeah damage control
I'll doing it as it is in the comics and
keep in that tone because it really is a
great comic series if we get any of the
Netflix characters they should do
daughters of the dragon before they
would do here's a Heroes for Hire mainly
because the fandom the Phantom behind
these shows that is vocal even though
we've seen like some statistics recently
they're like the word around Luke eight
season 2 a 9 for season 2 is pretty low
the support behind
Simone mythic as misty Knight and
calling winged Jessica hen wicks calling
wing is its way they also I think
they're kind of better actors all the
way around so I daughters of the Dragon
series or even Heroes for Hire and there
they're the main characters of that show
with Luke and Danny being a part of it
as well but and I think I relegated to
like side characters on the show I mean
I don't know maybe it's maybe it's them
for all together but they are really
good characters and their strong actors
and they have support so Disney if
you're gonna pick some characters pick
them a little bone to pick with this
whole thing about Luke Cage and iron
fist apparently the word is they got
cancelled because there wasn't enough
social media conversation no no people
were tweeting about the shows that's how
they valued it to its success or not so
it's like social media and people that
are very vocal are dictating what we can
and can't be watching these days do you
think that's true that's what the report
said that there's just less online
traffic because that's the only thing we
can know but netflix has their numbers
of how many people are watching don't
release their routines anyone about them
and their benefit but I bet Netflix is
kind of like if everyone was watching it
and it weren't being talked about or not
they probably would have kept it mm-hmm
but yeah I mean
I think that maybe that's the closest
thing we can use is social media because
it's true like when we would do videos
about it you guys remember we used to do
videos constantly about the the Netflix
universe our Bell universe and then Iron
Fist came out and then we kind of had to
stop because you guys didn't even want
to watch Wow videos about these things
you did I mean we cared enough to make
them right right it's like we clearly
were the people that cared but they're
just like it was a measurable difference
where we had to stop yeah the best
metric we have to go off of because
sometimes we look at ratings and box
office and things like that so to decide
and it's also based off of what we're
interested in but like yeah we can see
on like Google search stuff like how
much people are googling things how much
people are searching on YouTube for
things you know what's interesting is
when we look at stuff like we looked at
Luke Cage and iron fist they were around
we're like Jessica Jones and daredevil
season 3 work and way higher then other
Netflix shows like probably American
vandal or orange is the new black or
glow or or this new the haunting of Hill
House like I search for that and maniac
those things are like bottoming out like
not a lot of people at least like with
Luke Cage there's like blips on the
radar so it's interesting like maybe
it's may be comparatively from their
first season it must just cost them
because it's like even looking at maniac
the set design and the like how they
built out that woods it's mind-blowing
and talent like Jonah Hill's God let's
get back into the idea of I'm gonna
throw one out there and I want to hear
somebody taught me with a weirder one
but I would love for Hawkeye to finally
get his and he gets a show where he's
essentially Jason Bourne because that's
what they try to do and the next Tom
Cruise even know
my - if you're gonna do that bring Kate
Bishop on she's the other Hawkeye and I
want two seats and she's my favorite
Hawkeye so and do like a it's make it
spy stuff and or make it street-level if
you want to either way Hawkeye works
that works for both and have her either
he's training her or thinking he's
training her but she's already like
paste it she's already like a equal to
whatever it out yeah this guy is studio
thank you look at me give me something
weirder a weirder show deny
Quicksilver but right before he shot he
runs around the world and like lives his
last days it makes I don't really it
makes sense but we could try it Aaron
taylor-johnson you got it I love that
everybody else would be in slow motion
so he'd be like living his last life of
people maybe runs back in time oh and
then comes back to get killed yeah he's
got to because time starts getting all
messy no sir doctor who reference I
don't know yeah yeah
one of you said earlier in the Salonika
one of you said Afghan OHS origin story
which I thought was actually pretty cool
oh yeah something with his parents and a
large and or just like essentially is
something out there instead of something
down here
yeah a cosmic story how about this you
take Nick Spencer great writer he's
right and spider-man right now he did a
superior foes of spider-man and it was
about the sinister six but was always
five people and they're all like the
lamest like like and they're like it's
part of the it's part of the Oulu or
like everyone's like where's the sixth
guy micro today and they're all awful
they're so incompetent and the leaders
always just lying he's always lying even
to you the reader it's it's got some of
my favorite moments in like comics it
will make it it'll tickle you it'll make
you mickey giggle it's a good story and
I think like incompetent bank robbers is
a fun concept that like Marvel and then
with marble you get fun costumes too so
maybe you can be fun there there was
that deleted scene from throw Ragnarok
where Auden was homeless right I
wouldn't see how about and
where people think they can make him
fight another homeless person cruelly
I'll just throw out there finally the
last one I think my head every go I'm
gonna say no it is yes if you wanted a
kind of like traveling with this like
sadder hero throughout like a wide like
Silver Surfer you go to different worlds
and I want something very cool but just
do the Fantastic Four there yeah just
stop trying to do movies and just do the
people oh yeah
moving on to some other stuff yes
interesting bit of information came out
about Joaquin Phoenix's Drake a movie
basically walk in yeah he's back can't
call that okay please hey anyway gonna
be in it even as a kid nope no Batman in
this movie at all the actor that was
cast to play Bruce Wayne Dante Piero
also looks to be about nine years old so
he's not gonna even be Batman yet
Bruce's blue eyes so yeah this is like
obviously setting the timeline big time
a little funny and confusing fact that
this is a young actor actually played a
young Joaquin Phoenix that's how I say
his name okay Joaquin Joaquin like he's
walk in here walk in here yeah yeah
walking so sure but I mean there's not
much to say it's just that you know
there's not gonna be Batman it's gonna
be well before that time and the only
thing that you can kind of dissect from
that is the joke is gonna be well real
twisted before Batman becomes a man yeah
I have a hot take about this Gotham
already didn't so now you're just
digging into what Gotham did you'd play
with Gotham scraps but it worked on
we didn't the joker play it was the
young Joker on Gotham was named Jerome
something and then you found out he had
an evil twin who turns into the Joker
doesn't even why I don't watch god
you're embarrassing me like five
different people Sam are you hiding like
M&Ms in the years ago when I was running
SuperSpeed I kind of had but a brick
wall so my school's like jelly beans
right now yeah I think it is weird
though establishing this timeline that
when Batman gets older he's fighting a
Joker who's like thirty years older than
him right that's odd kid look like a
small Victorian boy like you know you
could have an older yeah but it wasn't
like you know as good as it gets Jack
Nicholson fighting him there's talk
about like just a couple years after the
shining Jack Nicholson was still kind of
jumped ahead like a decade 88 it is
right there shining was 83 oh and that
movie the first one was yeah you're
right there's a nice six years so the
[Laughter]
new Wonder Woman 84 I don't know if you
guys heard about this had moved it to a
lease date so summer 2020 which is
actually they moved it to the same
weekend that they released the original
one because like if it ain't broke June
yeah now uh I don't know this for sure
did they move it to the same weekend as
guardians of galaxy was gonna be mmm
or do they move Wonder Woman and they
moved in a different movie to that
weekend Godzilla something I don't know
about where it came from but I was
thinking like it definitely would make a
lot of sense of guardians like freeze it
up if DC just admittedly like oh thank
god okay we didn't want to go up against
you yeah kids guardians got pushed back
and what's gonna be 2020 got pushed back
2021 right
yeah also uh someone oh I got a credit
them but if we pull up a picture on my I
got this sent to me on Instagram filming
on Instagram someone thinks they spotted
a tiny baby Baltimore in the collectors
well he was a baby sovaldi and man I
can't even find him anymore but yeah so
dude first of all take a look at this
picture do you guys think that that's
that is what we're seeing is a little
Baltimore it's in the collectors place
you know what it looks like to me it
looks like that episode of of The Fresh
Prince of bel-air where Will's dad
abandons him and then they they zoom in
on that statue of the father and son
clutching each other at the end and he's
like why don't know what my Uncle Phil
and he cries that's what it looks like
hold up the picture that he's
referencing I don't remember that part
of that scene but I cried at the end
good show well if you look at it the
other way because you're looking at it
as well more in a fetal position but if
you turn it around it looks like the
character that Rex is in Mass Effect the
alien species that are usually well I
mean you're asking my opinion and that's
what I said yeah it's like a reptilian
sort of humanoid big bulky tank creature
like a xenomorph chestburster or
something like that also the way that
they would be on the side like the DJ
like was all coiled up anyway John Joe
Williams that's who it was thank you
appreciate a gram and then also any
Baltimore we do ours Baltimore News
there's a rumor that Henry Cavill is
going to actually end up appearing as
Superman or maybe even just as Clark
Kent one last time in the post-credits
scene first as I am
I would love to see him one last night
yeah like you know just like I'm back
happens to head and I'm back and then
like they never see it wasn't it like
there was negotiations over him
appearing and Shazam that led to like
the con or the negotiations and it looks
like him and and they CG either resting
place upper lip from justice okay
alright and then also Zack Snyder
revealed that there was a different
ending to Justice lousier eyes this lot
of us did too
instead of it ending the way it did it
would have ended with the heroes I'm
assuming heaven just defeated
looking up through a boom to who used to
wear those in the night okay so you if
you know boom tubes it's what Dark Side
would potentially be using to travel to
earth a woman like you waved when I was
little I used to think that you could do
that to China if you Joe the whole
that's exactly the same thing yeah at
the end of the movie you actually almost
see it because you see Steppenwolf and
the parademons pulling him up into
something so they'd already been right
there if he was peeking down maybe think
it's very elicited baby what the hell is
that
there's walk over yeah why do you think
do you think that maybe they're like we
don't want to commit to a big man yeah
like the test screenings maybe weren't
going great or something probably
and then finally James Wan tweeted out
just a nice little picture of nice to
look at its of all command characters
riding sharks like horses who hasn't
wanted to do this and say we're a little
girl crazy as this is practical so cool
I got a Mosasaurus see crocodile looking
thing they they genetically resurrected
it yeah you know yeah Willem Dafoe's
actual shark yeah just swim on their own
why do they gotta ride them well cuz
they're very good at swimming they're
very fast so I don't know why these are
no I don't know why they need to get
tired we saw Aquaman swim like a torpedo
I think it's to enslave fish kind feel I
gotta be a hierarchy you know Cheryl
here yep that's how we get to school
every morning
can we somebody Photoshop that for us
mod on our way to school bag of a shark
time for lightning right Jeff thanks
this means Jeff this is when we start
our lightning what a blast this is when
we new rock stars
pull your questions yes you tweeted us
questions I'm gonna fire them at our
co-host usually it's the other people
but old sans got the power today haha
you guys have to answer these as quickly
as possible without hesitation are you
ready bananas yes I'm ready are you
ready Phillip yeah you ready Maude hmm
all right buckle up here we go first one
goes to Sam at Rob's Parker favorite
character from daredevil season 3 that
would be bullseye next up go either at
sensei underscore M does Erik which too
horrible which two horror monsters would
you like to see clash in a versus film
oh I want to see it follows and the
thing who see if fellas has sex of the
thicker than follows no that's not how
it works this is from Karissa main hey
Chris if you had to go as any other
youtuber for Halloween who would you go
as ooh
Alex question oh I know who I wouldn't
what
name what's her name puppy goodness I
was like a dominatrix oh she had human
puppies on the carpet yo at Madison lay
87 what MCU movie post Avengers 4 are
you most excited for two fours in that
lightening lightening lightening
lightening lightening lightening
lightening lightening my good I want a
really good lightening absence a
underscore in with Halloween success
which horror icon would you like to get
rebooted I don't do that one don't do
that oh do a Hellraiser oh yeah because
it how is it really cool and a
generation doesn't really know he'll
raise there we go
that's this for Sam at Jeffrey - Carter
who would win in a fight Mogo the Living
Planet you DC or ego the Living Planet
Marvel Mogo cuz he's a Green Lantern he
could make Green Lantern stuff and
lastly this is - all at Cappy kid
favorite and worst Halloween candy
starting with mod favorite and worst oh
you guys don't know my candy picnic bars
hey guys that's a made-up one you make
it home do you mean black Australian
candy guys yeah all right Philip yeah
worst candy corn easy best full-size
king size Snickers bar interest is a
chocolate no picnic bar he's a Chomper
that had like oh no no you gotta keep
going back on that love child - chomp
bar chompers excessive weight stoppers a
Tim Tam mixed with
[Laughter]
well look em up that's not good
oh my favorite would have to be the
little boxes a dots that you can get rip
out your feelings and then my least
favorite are the apples that have razor
blades in them no the orange taffy you
know that weird orange and brown and
black taffy that has no like brand name
on it
Bobbie Debbie's delicious it's just as
weird like unmarked taffy that is Rachel
Blitzen have some weird answers
favorites a tie between Twix and a sour
patch product worst is dots cuz that's
not mine thank you all for this question
it's happy Halloween shout out any other
one when it starts mod go for it making
better season two nice that was quick
who was it who's really seen the first
episode so far but it's really great
it's nine years past the eviction of the
eviction the Commission conviction of
the the first round and in this time
there isn't a really brilliant female
lawyer that comes in and he's going to
unravel and destroy the case it's an old
dish one but actually just a goat you
haven't seen this you probably have it
go fine on on either iTunes or on the
Google Play Store a movie called
coherence love this movie it's it's I
don't want to tell you I don't like look
up too much whatever but it is it's not
like that but it's just sci-fi but just
so cool but you can mess it up yourself
so don't look it up just watch also it's
the only other thing Nicholas Brendon
ever did after Buffy on Netflix like
just go find it it's just like a good a
good if you're looking for another kind
of scary movie to watch on over this
next week the invitation on Netflix it's
another one of these movies like
coherence that I highly
commend it's just like I don't even want
to tell you what happens in it's just
like a very simple kind of scary thing
with some great actors and I think lo
commercial green is in it and the guy
who John Carroll Lynch is in his
favorite character is so good and zodiac
he's an amazing zodiac he's in one of
the best episodes of The Walking Dead
and the Pend Oreille show he's great and
he's in it's fantastic so the invitation
go watch it yes and they have seen that
one my recommendation if you want
something a little bit happy for Holly I
know boom check out I said this last
week but please watch Hilda it's an
animated series on Netflix they're
canceling so many shows this week please
don't cancel this show it will warm your
heart and they're getting a season -
lets get a season three sounds good so
check out all those things guys and
before we move under a trippy answer let
us let us reveal the winner of our
costume mashup contest the name is
litter glitter object Twitter object
Thank You properties are being mashed up
here pitbull and Star Wars an
interesting text right I wore it similar
tux like that in high school because I'm
like oh what if white was a color that I
usually went all the way with you said
you wore that to school well I did on
the week of a play I was doing wear that
was a costume and I'm like oh I'll just
work all week I also did a presentation
on the light versus dark imagery in
Apocalypse Now and that was like part of
my presentation triple-whammy really
know what it actually was I don't think
it was a reference to but
congratulations and you will be
receiving will reach out to you on
Twitter you'll be receiving a $25
Fandango gift card you got to have a
prize the first time and the second time
we talked about this eventually we threw
in a prize and I get a prize that's why
it's always fun to play yeah we always
play always always play and let us move
on to our trivia answer
before was what is crossbones real name
the loser as decided by our judges will
have to say the I gave you your own will
have to join the gif now he also gave me
and I'll take Phillips okay so what did
we say
Erik said Brock Bruno Rock Bruno I think
it's brought something fimo said Brock
rumlow cool mod said Brock Rambo and sam
says Brook rums a good drink Brock
rumlow and it spelled with a W so the
winner I think someone said it exactly
probably Phil so I I wrote it exactly
but I totally heard Sam earlier just say
his name was Brock rumlow but I'm being
honest about that Hey but that's honesty
is the best policy so I think I'm not
the judge why am i weighing in yeah
judges so who lost I think Sam should
win Brock Bruno is Eric's answer because
Sam actually knew it Sam yeah drew it
from his own mental bit oh you're doing
that thing where you're talking a lot so
we don't pick you Eric had the worst
[Music]
okay you know you're all my friends if
you think about I love all of you don't
make me do this okay so I'm gonna join
gif of shame it's really hard to gift me
cuz I'm wearing a hot dog in a and a
shark but we got some new ones don't
live on the Internet forever oh I like
that a contact lens is sliding back into
your eyeball that's so specific that was
mine okay so our winner Sam will radar
good shame ones gonna chant shame at me
that's punished yeah this is cool happy
Halloween there it is there it is boys
and girls but oh wow he's really nailing
you get it can you get it on quotas
alright can you get it out oh you look
like you're about to cry
it well well guys thank you for watching
this week's episode new rockstars news I
want to thank our host means Sam basher
on Twitter Eric Foss a TA Vostro Molina
at FEMA and Maude Garrett at McGarrett
happy Halloween but comment down below
and tweet at us well wrong stars like
this video share it around and subscribe
to Rutgers for a deep dive into stubble
you up next time bye bye happy Halloween